Cyberbullying and violence can be a persistent problem for kids of all ages, in schools, and even at home. One out of three students is bullied during the school year, according to the National Center for Educational Statistics. It's a problem that is dramatically affecting the mental health of young people in a variety of ways. In this episode, we speak with one psychologist about why school-wide anti-bullying and anti-violence programs are so important. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. psychology. Dorothy Espelage is a professor of educational psychology at the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign. She has been conducting research on bullying, sexual harassment, dating violence, and gang violence for the last 20 years. She is associate editor of the Journal of Counseling Psychology
网络欺凌和暴力对于各个年龄段的孩子来说，无论是在学校还是在家里，都可能是一个持续存在的问题。根据国家教育统计中心的数据，每三个学生中就有一个在学年中遭受过欺凌。这是一个以多种方式严重影响年轻人心理健康的问题。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，探讨为什么全校范围内的反欺凌和反暴力项目如此重要。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。多萝西·埃斯佩拉格是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校的教育心理学教授。在过去的20年里，她一直致力于欺凌、性骚扰、约会暴力和帮派暴力的研究。她是《咨询心理学杂志》的副主编，
and is author of more than 120 peer-reviewed journal articles. Welcome, Dr. Espelage. Thank you for having me. The psychological study of bullies and bullying has come a long way. I think there's been a lot more awareness of the issue and what it means for children's mental health. Has all this awareness made a difference from what you've seen in the research and the prevalence of bullying and aggression in schools? Certainly there has been a heightened awareness. We have studied it for a number of decades, but it wasn't until 2011 when President Obama had his White House conference on bullying that really the public took notice of bullying. It's difficult to estimate whether or not this awareness has contributed to a decrease in the prevalence of it, but certainly we do.
并且是120多篇同行评审期刊文章的作者。欢迎您，埃斯佩拉格博士。谢谢你邀请我。对欺凌者和欺凌行为的心理学研究已经取得了长足的进步。我认为人们对这个问题以及它对儿童心理健康意味着什么的认识已经大大提高。从你的研究以及学校中欺凌和攻击行为的普遍程度来看，所有这些认识是否带来了改变？当然，人们的认识确实提高了。我们已经研究了几十年，但直到2011年奥巴马总统召开白宫欺凌问题会议，公众才真正注意到欺凌问题。很难估计这种认识是否促成了欺凌现象的减少，但我们确实，
know from national statistics that in some schools where there's lower violence, we've seen less bullying. But certainly in our studies, and we're engaged in studies in hundreds of schools right now, it's still alive and well in our schools, and we need to be concerned about it, and it's a difficult behavior to decrease. What do we know about what predicts involvement in bullying and aggression? You know, you hear video games, you know, other types of media. How much do we know about what causes it? Yeah, we know that actually, you know, predicting who's going to be involved as someone that is what we call a perpetrator or a target is very, very complex. And so it just really depends on their home environment.
从国家统计数据中了解到，在一些暴力程度较低的学校，我们看到的欺凌现象较少。但在我们的研究中——我们目前正在数百所学校进行研究——欺凌现象在学校里依然存在，我们需要对此保持关注，而且这是一种很难减少的行为。关于什么可以预测欺凌和攻击行为的参与，我们了解多少？你知道，你会听到电子游戏，或者其他类型的媒体。我们对它的成因了解多少？是的，我们知道，实际上，预测谁会成为所谓的施暴者或目标是非常、非常复杂的。这真的取决于他们的家庭环境。
It depends on a child's school, whether or not they have anti-bullying policies in place. It's whether or not they're in middle school. In middle school, bullying tends to be concentrated among some of the most popular kids. When kids are younger, they seem to kind of navigate this, and kids that engage in bullying behaviors are rejected. but by middle school, they really do have high social status. By high school, it really nuances into sexual harassment and teen dating violence. So I think what we do know is that there's not a deterministic model. We can't predict who's going to be involved in bullying as a perpetrator or a victim,
这取决于孩子的学校，以及学校是否制定了反欺凌政策。这还取决于他们是否在读初中。在初中，欺凌往往集中在一些最受欢迎的孩子身上。当孩子还小的时候，他们似乎能处理好这些关系，参与欺凌行为的孩子会被排斥。但到了初中，他们确实拥有很高的社会地位。到了高中，它就演变成了性骚扰和青少年约会暴力。所以我认为我们所知道的是，并没有一个决定论的模型。我们无法预测谁会作为施暴者或受害者参与到欺凌中，
but we certainly do know that there's certain risk factors, and that could be violence in the home, it could be neighborhoods in which they're witnessing violence. It could be that you have a sibling that is aggressive towards you and then you play that behavior out in school. We also know that school climate matters. So if I'm in a school in which there's no anti-bullying policies and the teachers model violence or they actually bully themselves, then the kids are more likely to bully.
但我们确实知道存在某些风险因素，这可能是家庭暴力，也可能是他们目睹暴力的社区环境。也可能是因为你有兄弟姐妹对你表现出攻击性，然后你在学校里重演了这种行为。我们还知道学校氛围很重要。所以，如果我所在的学校没有反欺凌政策，老师们以身作则表现出暴力，或者他们自己就参与欺凌，那么孩子们就更有可能去欺凌别人。
But if I'm in a school in which it's not tolerated, then I'm less likely to engage in that behavior. And so certainly we know that there might be individual characteristics that predict whether or not I'm going to engage in this behaviors, but it's not deterministic. It depends on their larger social environment. And a lot of your research does focus on the schools and their role in bullying and aggression. What role do schools play in bullying and how can they play? prevent it from becoming a widespread problem. You go into more detail on that. Certainly. I mean, kids spend more time in schools than they do sometimes even with their
但如果我所在的学校不容忍这种行为，那么我参与这种行为的可能性就较小。因此，我们当然知道可能存在一些个人特征可以预测我是否会参与这些行为，但这并不是决定性的。这取决于他们更大的社会环境。你的很多研究确实集中在学校及其在欺凌和攻击行为中的作用。学校在欺凌中扮演什么角色，他们如何防止其成为一个普遍的问题？请详细说明一下。当然。我的意思是，孩子们在学校待的时间有时甚至比他们与
parents or in their neighborhoods or in their home. So the school is pivotal. Now, the school is not the only place where we need to intervene, but certainly we do know from our research that if we implement what we call social emotional learning programs where we teach kids' empathy and perspective taking, how to communicate, how to problem solve, how to resolve conflicts. We have less bullying. We have less sexual harassment. And so certainly schools do play a role. We also know that a lot of people talk about, oh, the epidemic is cyberbullying. Bottom line is that most of the conflicts that play out through media and through the internet actually start at school. So the schools play a pivotal role in creating a positive school climate
父母在一起，或者在社区或家里待的时间还要长。所以学校是关键。现在，学校并不是我们唯一需要干预的地方，但我们从研究中确实知道，如果我们实施所谓的社会情感学习项目，教导孩子同理心和换位思考，如何沟通，如何解决问题，如何化解冲突，我们就能减少欺凌。我们就能减少性骚扰。所以学校确实发挥了作用。我们也知道，很多人谈论说，哦，流行病是网络欺凌。底线是，大多数通过媒体和互联网表现出来的冲突实际上始于学校。因此，学校在营造积极的学校氛围方面发挥着关键作用，
so that when kids do pick up technology, they're less likely to be mean and cruel. Another area of research that you're focusing on now is sexual harassment and teen dating violence. How serious is this problem among middle and high school students specifically? Yeah, and I mean it's hard for anybody listening to this to think that a sixth grader who's 10 years old would engage in any type of inappropriate sexual commentary or rumor spreading. But we do know that about 30% of six through eighth graders engage in unwanted sexual commentary and sexual rumor spreading. Luckily, only 1 to 3% of 6th through 8th graders report being inappropriately touched, but we do know that that number goes up quite substantially in high school. And the bottom line is if we do not, high school is too late to start talking about sexual harassment.
这样当孩子们接触技术时，他们就不太可能变得刻薄和残忍。你现在关注的另一个研究领域是性骚扰和青少年约会暴力。这个问题在初中生和高中生中具体有多严重？是的，我的意思是，对于任何听众来说，很难想象一个10岁的六年级学生会进行任何类型的性评论或散布谣言。但我们确实知道，大约30%的六到八年级学生参与过不受欢迎的性评论和性谣言传播。幸运的是，只有1%到3%的六到八年级学生报告说被不适当地触摸，但我们确实知道这个数字在高中阶段会大幅上升。底线是，如果我们不这样做，高中才开始谈论性骚扰就太晚了。
And we're in the United States, and sexual harassment is illegal in K through 12, just as it is in workplaces. And so we need to start talking to kids about the sexual commentary they use so that it doesn't escalate to the unwanted sexual harassment, though that is quite prevalent in high school. You mentioned before that schools aren't the only places where all of this needs to be having. Can you give some examples of other areas that needs to improvement? Certainly. I mean, I think that schools are pivotal, but the reality is that kids reside in other context, right? So we have to think about even boys and girls clubs. We have to think about sport, right? So only now
而且我们是在美国，性骚扰在K-12（幼儿园到高中）阶段是非法的，就像在工作场所一样。所以我们需要开始和孩子们谈论他们使用的性评论，这样它就不会升级为不受欢迎的性骚扰，尽管这在高中确实很普遍。你之前提到学校并不是所有这些问题都需要解决的唯一地方。你能举一些其他需要改进的领域的例子吗？当然。我的意思是，我认为学校是关键，但现实是孩子们还生活在其他环境中，对吧？所以我们必须考虑男孩女孩俱乐部。我们必须考虑体育运动，对吧？所以只有现在，
our coaches starting to think like, okay, maybe I play a role in the escalation of bullying or sexual harassment. In the home, parents need to have open dialogues with their youth about what they're doing online, who they're engaging with. If parents are listening now, talk to their kids about sexual harassment, talk to them about bullying, are they those good kids that just go along with that kind of bully ringleader? All of us need to have this conversation. It should happen in churches. It should happen anywhere that you have a child and you interact with a child, these conversations need to happen. I think parents also have this idea that the schools have to do something about the bullying. You hear that a lot, and I'm a parent, so I know even in elementary school you say, well,
我们的教练才开始想，好吧，也许我在欺凌或性骚扰的升级中扮演了某种角色。在家里，父母需要与他们的孩子就他们在网上做什么、与谁交往进行公开对话。如果父母现在正在听，请和他们的孩子谈谈性骚扰，谈谈欺凌，他们是那些只是随波逐流、跟着欺凌领头羊走的“好孩子”吗？我们所有人都需要进行这种对话。它应该发生在教堂里。它应该发生在任何你有孩子并与孩子互动的地方，这些对话都需要发生。我认为父母也有这种想法，即学校必须对欺凌行为采取行动。你经常听到这种说法，我也是一位家长，所以我知道即使在小学，你也会说，好吧，
this needs to be handled. I mean, how do you go, what is the best way to go about getting the school to intervene or having the parent involved? I mean, what sort of level of coordination do you need there? Well, I mean, I think that we know from, you know, systematic studies that if we address the issue of bullying and sexual harassment and teen dating violence from all directions in the home and in the school. But the reality is kids spend a lot of time in the schools and schools are mandated. Unfortunately, there are law. I mean, there are unfunded mandates, right? So schools are told you will address the bullying problem, but we're not going to give you any funds to do this.
这需要处理。我的意思是，你如何去，让学校介入或让家长参与的最佳方式是什么？我的意思是，你需要什么样的协调水平？嗯，我的意思是，我认为我们从系统性的研究中知道，如果我们从家庭和学校的所有方向解决欺凌、性骚扰和青少年约会暴力问题。但现实是孩子们在学校花了很多时间，而且学校是强制性的。不幸的是，有法律。我的意思是，有无资金支持的授权，对吧？所以学校被告知你必须解决欺凌问题，但我们不会给你任何资金来做这件事。
And your teachers are overworked and the teachers feel they have to address bullying and put that on their plate along with other things that they have to address in the social ills. The reality is that in our research we find that if in fact schools are addressing it and teachers feel supported by their administration to address the bullying problem, they feel that they can dialogue with the parents, there's less bullying. So again, it's not just that there's a quick fix. There's not a quick fix. We know that if it's a positive school climate and kids like going to school and they're connected with their teachers, there's less bullying. And so that's just one area where we can address it, but certainly we can't do it without
而且你的老师工作过度，老师们觉得他们必须解决欺凌问题，并把这和其他他们必须解决的社会弊病一起放在他们的工作清单上。现实情况是，在我们的研究中，我们发现如果学校确实在解决这个问题，并且老师们感到得到了管理层的支持来解决欺凌问题，他们觉得可以与家长对话，那么欺凌现象就会减少。所以，这并不是说有一个快速的解决方案。没有快速的解决方案。我们知道，如果学校氛围积极，孩子们喜欢上学，并且与老师建立了联系，欺凌现象就会减少。所以这只是我们可以解决的一个领域，但我们当然不能在没有
the parents. We actually know that kids that are when they're bullied online, 85% of the time, they're at home. And so when I talk to parents, like, I need, parents need to engage with the schools or needs to be an open form of communication. We can't do it alone. All of us need to get on the same page. Thank you, Dr. Esplod.
家长的情况下做到这一点。我们实际上知道，当孩子们在网上被欺凌时，85%的情况下，他们是在家里。所以当我与家长交谈时，我需要，家长需要与学校互动，需要有一种开放的沟通形式。我们不能独自完成。我们所有人都需要达成共识。谢谢你，埃斯佩拉格博士。
Very interesting. Thank you for joining us. Thank you. For more information on Dr. Espelage's work and to hear more episodes, please go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常有趣。谢谢你加入我们。谢谢。有关埃斯佩拉格博士工作的更多信息以及收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。